[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
we're going to be breaking down Gemini
man starring Will Smith and Will Smith
throughout this video I'm gonna be
discussing everything that you need to
know about the film as well as its
ending make sure you stick around until
the end of the video for my review where
I'll be telling you if this movie is The
Fresh Prince of rotten tomatoes or more
will I am sorry all the will.i.am fans
out there they're both a year anyway
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want the movie ruined then
now's the time to back out without the
way I just want to give a huge thank you
for clicking this video now let's get
into our breakdown of Gemini man Gemini
man follows Henry Brogan
one of the world's best assassins that
makes Deadshot look like a storm trooper
the film opens with him on a mission to
kill a man aboard a train and whilst he
completes this due to the presence of a
young girl in the cabin he realizes that
morally he's no longer cut out for the
life disillusioned with the job and due
to the fact that his emotions are
getting in the way he decides to take a
step back and live life at tony stark
shack in the wilderness i heard they're
selling the house now cuz i never never
mind anyway henry is pretty much
irreplaceable but against his bosses
best wishes he still decides to step
back later learning that the person he
assassinated at the start was an
innocent biologist his former employees
have literal eyes in the sky and decide
it's time to take him down this is where
we are introduced to clay Varys played
by Clive Owen head of a project named
Gemini as much as I'm sure clay loved
star signs and horoscopes the project
actually revolves around creating clones
in order to carry out their jobs of
killing him billing if you've ever seen
a hitman movie before then you know the
gist by now and I really don't know why
they can't make a film about an assassin
that isn't about the agency that hired
them turning against them anyway where
Gemini man tries to diversify this
cliche is that the company have created
a perfect clone of Henry and they decide
that now is the time to bring him into
action in order to kill his prototype
and his eyes there's flashes of the
Metal Gear Solid series throughout the
and this film is as much about feeling
like you've had your identity taken away
as we see with the older brogan to
feeling like you don't really have one
which is reflected in his younger
counterpart the movie has a really
interesting aesthetic to it and early on
it's intense watching Henry being
tracked down by his duplicate who seems
to almost out match him in every
department this leads to an outstanding
bike chase and some great standoffs
especially one at night when the two
characters come face to face and realize
what's been going on the entire time now
the technology behind the movie which
allows for a younger version of Smith to
appear on screen with himself is really
the film's main selling point and at
certain times it looks very convincing
especially during the aforementioned
night scene however during the daylight
and when the two share the same screen
it falls victim to the uncanny valley
and can be quite jarring this is pretty
much being marketed as a game changer
but in all honesty it falls short of
Marvel's efforts with a younger version
of samuel l.jackson and Captain Marvel
by far besting this it's very much make
a break for the movie and in the same
way that Superman's mustache sure in the
Justice League for many this also will
probably take a lot of viewers out of
the action in the film's defense the
acting is really on point and even
without the tech being there for Smith
he still manages to portray a younger
version of himself convincingly he
really is one of our best actors and as
usual he nails the role and has a
charisma that makes him likable even
though we know he's done a lot of bad
things mirroring this the younger
version of himself Junior
two comes across as naive in a way that
makes it hard not to root for him we
learned that the target on the train
used to be working for Gemini and we
discovered that the company have managed
to create duplicates that don't have
emotion and therefore won't run into the
same moral issues as Henry Henry sets up
a trap for jr. and confronts him
exposing the truth and also using
apparent secrets about himself to
confirm that they are duplicates now
this was a big tease in the trailer with
the big mystery of the movie hanging
around this reveal and if you've come to
this video just to know what it is then
prepared to be disappointed the scene
and the trailer isn't really in the film
and it's reworked differently so that
Henry just brings up things that they
have in
he says that they suffer from insomnia
and are celibate due to the fear of
losing love should someone discover what
they are it's a pretty big ding on the
movie especially if you were curious
about this and almost feel slightly like
false advertising with this being one of
the main things that I was excited for
with the film anyway Jr and Henry end up
joining forces in order to take down
clay in Gemini but they are tracked by
another clone who unlike them feels
absolutely nothing this is sort of the
Metal Gear aspect that I was alluding to
earlier with there being big
similarities between the cloning a big
boss into solid solidus and liquid it
becomes clear that clay is just going to
pump these out and make Will Smith make
men and black movies till the end of
time and he reveals they were intending
to make armies based on the character
jr. stands up against clay and almost
kills him until Henry talks him out of
it making sure that he doesn't travel
down the same path that created all of
this misery it allows jr. to truly gain
his humanity and Henry instead kills
clay taking the blood on his hands this
means that the cycle has finally ended
and that there will be no more clones
produced and they are finally free from
the attacks by Gemini we pick up with
jr. receiving a new identity something
that he can truly make his own instead
of living in Henry shadow and he has
adopted the name Jackson which is
Henry's mother's maiden name Jr says
he's going to be okay and we get the
impression that they are going to
develop a father-and-son relationship
together which ends the film but what
did I think of Gemini man well I think
your impressions of Gemini Man will be
based on how many movies like this that
you've seen it's purely aimed at teens
and I can't see a lot of people in that
age bracket enjoying it and finding fun
through the film however I've seen it's
done a lot of times and with the
slightly underperforming D aging
technique pretty much rampant throughout
the film it makes it a bit difficult to
be fully invested in now Gemini man
isn't a bad film
it's very competent and has some great
action set-pieces however it doesn't
quite knock it out of the park to be
anything other than a technology
showcase and another vehicle for Will
Smith I was really hoping that this
would be incredible but it falls
slightly flattened some areas making it
a bit
men overall it's a fun ride that you
won't remember this time next week but
it's still worth a visit if you've
already watched Joker Gemini man gets a
six point five out of ten
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film and if you agree
with my score or not comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my end they explained
breakdown of last week's big release of
Joker which should be linked at the end
I'll give my interpretations on the film
as well as what I took from it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to come
chat to me on Twitter make sure you
follow me a definition whitey and if you
want to join my discord to keep up to
date with the channel then make sure you
click on the link in the description
below we've got an awesome community
just like you that talk about movies TV
shows games and comic books so hopefully
I see you over there after this also
just wanna let you know that we're
currently giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on
Gemini man in the comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th in the blue robe doubt
from then to ever get surprised so best
of luck to everyone he takes part this
is a channel for people who were mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
you
[Music]